welcome this video I'm playing endless
fighter Grand Master and I don't know
who that is I can try again but if there
is no name in them maybe switch to to
something else just not the same opening
all the time this version of the London
is is in fact quite interesting to play
more interesting than some others um
camp going with C 3 but I'm not going to
play Knight f3 so quickly this gives
white some additional options I wonder
if you can play Bishop f5 and actually
ok it's not doing that so I'll complete
my development on Bishop t6 I have the
opportunity to take and play a form it's
quite nice sort of a stone wall without
them dark squared bishop ok I'm
interesting i should cover this poem of
course but but how exactly look be one
or quincy to queen be one Queen B 1
maybe if this has an eye on when the on
the age 7 pawn lotto could be useful
maybe you can play Knight h5 now I am
precisely ok i guess i have to move this
is threatening to take a take deform
okay so how to play this here maybe i
can i can try to to open up the position
while I have the slightly development it
is very slight okay taking a d4 may be
inevitable go back to e7
what directly you form to leaf or ed
four I can take on Ani former 94 CDF 96
check but this is really just a check
out it's not maybe cooking is seven
nights you form okay let's let's play
let's play me not think ages here takes
90 x CD 496 checking is 794 as my idea
try to use as then somewhat insecure
king position not sure how bad this is
see maybe can when the King has only
certain just play rookie yay taking
evade or something okay he ignored this
all together and just accepted the
isolated Queen porn position which is
not a problem for black of course was
just a very much keep it simple approach
okay i want i want to have some pressure
on the deep on
it should be 2nite FD for Bishop e3
something like that would be nice but
black black could simply play Bishop g4
you okay maybe wants to push it all the
way to a 3 mm I see normally you'd like
to play a 4 here but obviously the
splendors of the night so no I'm not a
good idea maybe maybe go here simply so
that a 4 can be answered with a 3 I
cannot grab on d4 I can play Bishop
takes 26 but this looks okay here right
shouldn't be worse for me yeah this is
opening wasn't too successful or
interesting so I'm okay with this equal
position huh surprised that you took
this I mean leg is ok here still but I
would have been reluctant to to capture
ok right if I go here yes Bishop f5 yeah
this is interesting in fact yes the
better piece coordination at the most
rooks here Mike we not be one is really
not good
well that's it surprisingly
uncomfortable in this position here
interesting um how do i how do I get
this coordinated ready that's a bishop
a4 sometimes yeah
hmm that's not good here really amazing
yeah I've seen this and it's not very
satisfactory that very satisfactorily
satisfactory but uh what what what was I
going to do I really don't know after
that you can can actually take one dear
forum
time morning Jim I know it looks a bit
but he cannot take on d4 I guess maybe I
have bishops e to be three or something
that's not really great if the bishop
maybe I can play this first so i have
this trick Bishop g6 still have this is
not a check here
and how do i untie this it's really
uncomfortable this position III before
maybe she going from age five I know I
can still take that now I have this move
Quincy six maybe but ok Quincy one is
now an idea put the Queen on c6 okay if
we go screen b6 back I probably go okay
I can a better offer this trade yeah
okay now I'm perfectly all right unless
I overlooked something directly here
that's it's actually quite okay now
should I should have played g3 really
let's do this coverage form yes some yes
Luke takes a 3m funny Luke takes a three
I know it doesn't look 21 Brooke f3q
okay the position is just slightly
better for me but 17 seconds will be
driven tricky and now it's clearly
better for what maybe g5 but cannot
really check check yeah the H point is
some small weakness I guess I know it
can I only have eight seconds of this is
this is the problem check Oh Jack Jack
White ah really got really got good
clothes in the end yeah here he ran out
of ideas and started to put all pawns on
light squares after which yeah here is
around here white is just a bit more
comfortable but it was it was impossible
to do anything anything really yeah
constructive with is 17 seconds um I
really think that this is just good no
white but I couldn't really do something
great f5s coutinho very good in fact
threatening f6 and the point is that my
bishop is just a much better pieces he
just has a tall ponyo on c6 yeah this
would have been very nice but
I didn't I didn't see that cat with no
time Atia the H porn is just just just a
problem but I couldn't I couldn't do
anything hidden meaningful with 8
seconds um it was really really a bit
annoying here is this type of situation
I couldn't move much here this is a very
good for black here i played this ok I
guess but somewhere later it was it was
it wasn't totally great here I mean this
I don't know yeah and after this i mean
the trade here white white is just
perfectly ok and the way you played them
it even switched in my favor he should
probably play h4 at some stage making
sure that i did don't get in g3 yeah ok
it was mostly decided by time i spent
far too much time thanks for watching